-Welcome back!
-It's great to be back.
-Last time you were here
was November, and you --
you basically laid out
that you thought Donald Trump
did not ever
want to be president.
What he would
so much rather be doing
is live-tweeting
"Fox & Friends."
-Exactly.
-And then this morning happened.
[ Laughter ]
So, is that his dream?
Like, what do you make of it?
-Well, I think that
there's reporting that indicates
that he wants
to do that every morning.
-Yeah.
-And they have to basically --
They basically have to --
They have to hold him back.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But I -- I think --
I mean, there was a moment --
The interview --
At the end of the interview --
-Yeah.
-When you're interviewing
the President
of the United States,
you push that
as long as you can, right?
I mean, you got
a million questions,
you keep them there,
keep them there.
It's like a scene in a movie
where they're tracing
the phone call.
-Yeah.
-It's like --
But it was the opposite.
They treated him
like he was a crazy caller
in they're call-in show.
-Yeah.
-And they had to get him off.
So by the end of it, it's like,
"Welp, anyway,
we should probably --
You're probably busy."
And he's like,
"No, I'm -- I'm pretty good.
I got all day, really."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
It was definitely --
Definitely wasn't thinking,
"I got to run out
and get that gift
for Melania," yeah.
[ Laughter ]
It was very surreal
to watch those three hosts
who probably more often than not
agree with the President,
but they did certainly
look as though they realized,
"Oh, this might not
be in his best interest."
What do you think
the energy was like
in the control room
for something like that?
-You know,
that is a great question.
There is --
You can see on their faces
that they are
slightly horrified.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Steve Doocy
does a patented grimace grin...
-Yeah.
-...where he, like,
slaps his knees, like...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-There's, like, a lot of that,
and so --
In the control room, I mean...
If I were in the control room,
you're thinking, like,
"Keep him going, keep him going,
keep him going."
But I think at a certain point,
I don't know if there's, like,
a protective instinct that
kicked in in that control room,
but they just moved it away.
-It's interesting, too,
because, obviously, you know,
Donald Trump loves
to frame himself as a victim,
and it's either the media
or the Democrats,
but so many of the things
that he has done,
he set into motion.
Obviously, when he fired Comey,
that started
a bunch of dominoes.
-Yep.
-The fact that Jeff Sessions
had to recuse himself
started a lot of dominoes.
It would be so ironic
if going on "Fox & Friends"
put him in a legal jackpot.
-I mean, literally --
literally, an hour later,
There was a filing in
Southern District of New York
in which
the government's attorneys
referenced the thing
that he said...
-Yeah.
-...on "Fox & Friends,"
when he basically said,
"Yeah, he's barely my lawyer,"
essentially.
-Yeah.
-While they're arguing,
simultaneously,
like, he's his lawyer.
All that
information's privileged.
-It is --
It's trippy to watch.
-It's trippy to watch,
and it's also --
I mean, it's why
people made this point.
He is -- He is the ultimate
nightmare client.
-Yeah.
-I mean, every lawyer
that I've ever talked to is just
like, "I would lose my mind.
I couldn't --
I could not put up with it.
It's the worst possible thing,"
because you've got
the most famous man in America
and the most powerful man
in America,
and the person
who will not listen to you,
and a person who always
thinks he can get by.
-Yeah.
-And that's the key.
I mean, that's, I think,
been his -- his --
That will, ultimately,
if it is his undoing,
that will be his undoing.
-And let's --
He also hates losers,
so if you were his lawyer...
[ Laughter ]
If you were his lawyer,
and you lost,
he's not the kind of guy
who's like,
"At least
you did your best, Ted."
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, you know,
we gave 'em hell."
[ Laughter ]
So, today seems
like a real crystallization
of what we have come to expect
from the Trump presidency,
although it just does --
it seems like every day
is a little bit more.
You know, you have Mike Pompeo
confirmed by the Senate.
This is a very hawkish
Secretary of State now.
You have Ronny Jackson --
Dr. Ronny Jackson stepping away
from his V.A. nomination.
You have Scott Pruitt basically
having to defend himself
against, basically,
these calls that he's been
a complete violator of ethics.
-10 different investigations.
How do you --
Do you think it's just too much
for people to process?
-I think it is hard to process.
I mean, it really is.
And there's, you know,
there's a -- [ Laughs ]
There's a moment --
There's a "Simpsons" moment
I keep coming back to,
where the doctor
tells Montgomery Burns
that he's being kept alive
because all these
different diseases
are fighting each other.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And it's like,
there's a little bit of that
with, like, Trump scandals.
-Right.
-Even Scott Pruitt right now --
Like, we had
an editorial meeting
this morning, and I was like,
"Well, we just got to pick one,
'cause we can't do the whole
show on Scott Pruitt.
So, like, what's the --
Are we doing the phone booth
or we doing the thing
he rented from the lobbyist?"
-Yeah.
-"Are we doing
the security stuff?
Like, what are we doing
on Scott Pruitt?"
So I think that there is --
there is a degree to which
the sheer volume of what's
been coming out
of the White House
and the administration
weirdly does kind of
help them a little bit,
because it can be
very difficult to focus.
-So I do think it helps him,
but it does --
what it doesn't seem to do
is help the people
who come in his orbit.
So, you know,
Scott Pruitt helped him today
by also being a --
a man of no ethics.
[ Laughter ]
You know, Dr. Ronny Jackson,
to some degree,
helped him for being a guy
who was in the news
that wasn't, you know, a Trump
story as much as other ones.
Is it, like -- Do you think now
people are realizing, like,
"Oh, I can't get near this guy."
-I think that has started
to dawn on people,
and I think there's a line
that Josh Marshall --
he's a writer -- he calls Trump
a "dignity wraith."
-Yeah.
-Right? Like, which is like,
if you come in his orbit,
like -- [ Inhaling sharply ]
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And it's like --
It's amazing.
People go in
with great reputations.
I mean, David Shulkin,
who was the V.A. Secretary,
holdover from Obama,
confirmed unanimously,
viewed as a really
stand-up, good guy,
has allegations that he --
you know, improperly spent money
on Wimbledon tickets.
He gets fired unceremoniously
in this very public,
humiliating way,
replaced by Ronny Jackson.
Again, holdover from
an Obama White House position,
has a generally good public
profile and a good reputation,
watches that reputation
absolutely be destroyed
in a matter of 48 hours,
and then sort of slinks back
into the job.
If you come
into contact with him,
you will have
your reputation destroyed.
-So I want to ask,
because I hadn't really
thought about this, but you
talk about Shulkin and Jackson.
Obviously,
they're Obama holdovers.
-Yeah.
-Do you think they --
It doesn't seem like they
started acting more like Trump.
It was more that
a light went on Trump...
-I think it's a little bit
of both, right?
So and I think Jackson --
Jackson's a very weird case
that I think I'm having
a hard time figuring out.
-Sure, 'cause he was a --
he was a Bush doctor,
he was an Obama doctor.
They all seemed to love him.
-And I think it's both, right?
I mean, I think one of it is
that people are gonna
assume the worst
if you're in his orbit
and will apply
that standard to you.
I think, also,
what we've seen happen,
and I'm not sure
if this happened to Shulkin,
but I think it's
happened with others is that,
the message is sent from the
top down about what's allowed.
-Right.
-Right? And if you've ever
worked in a big organization,
whether it's in government
or a business, if people --
if you know people
are cutting corners,
if you know people are hustling
and being dodgy,
that tends to trickle down
throughout an organization,
and everyone else starts
looking to get theirs.
And I think that's also
been a big factor
in a lot of the scandals coming
out of the administration.